[Music]
well if you thought today was going to
be just another average day think again
because Alex Rodriguez just danced
around in Jennifer Lopez's dress for the
whole internet to see yeah I'm serious a
rod dancing in J Lo's dress what can I
tell you here's what went down on Sunday
the former New York Yankees star took on
the flip the switch challenge with his
fiancee the challenge is simple stand in
front of him here with a friend with
Drake song non stop playing when the
rapper says flip the switch turn the
lights off then on and you and your
friend swap spots and clothes so you see
where this is going right
yeah that's JLo looking fire shaking it
like only she can in a skin-tight white
dress and that's a rod trying to shake
it like jen in the same white dress you
just can't unsee that can you
[Music]
the triple-threat shared the clip on
tick-tock alongside the caption wait for
it well we waited for it and needless to
say it was a hit
Lenny Kravitz commented on the post
quote get it bro well Jennifer's second
act co-star Vanessa Hudgens said what we
were all feeling I'm dead same girl same
of course
JLo and a rod aren't the only celebs
getting in on the challenge senator
Elizabeth Warren and Kate McKinnon tried
it out backstage at Saturday Night Live
over the weekend the best part is
watching Kate trying her best not to
laugh also get it Warren fYI she's 70
what a legend but back to j-rod you look
like you have in the damn time in your
life what do I I'm not gonna complain
about I mean my life right now is just
so amazing my personal life you know my
kids everything everything is just in a
great place and I feel really lucky
ya know like seriously nothing to
complain about she legit damn near broke
tick-tock when she shared this clip
recently
yeah that's JLo on the beach showing off
her killer beach bod guys she's 50/50
anyway that's it for today until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens I just flip the
switch okay that's not dancing that is
not dancing
[Music]